[Music]
is it true you moved back to
massachusetts you're obviously we're
both from massachusetts you moved back
what what what made you decide i've
started to like nature more and i don't
see a lot of nature in los angeles so i
wanted to be around talking about look
at this yeah
breeze coming in off the ocean that's
nice moon 10 times its normal size
is that really there even though that's
fake is it really there
what did you what did you ask me oh man
yeah i wanted to be back in nature
you know i live near walden pond you
know i go there i like to be in the wood
you know what fascinates me uh thoreau
was there very par everyone knows him
now million what kills me i think this
is funny although i won't laugh
no i think that it's funny that millions
of people go to see where this guy lives
yeah hilarious millions of people go
there
to see a hairman to see a place former
hermit a former hermit lived yes it's
called an fh
former hermit
it says on this on you're driving
towards walden fawn it says fh one mile
that's not true
[Laughter]
you're screwing with me and i won't have
it i'm very sorry how have you been how
are you on a scale of how are you in
general you don't care yes i do injury
you don't okay you don't you don't care
how i do you want me to not care no i
want you to care but i'm not sure you do
care do you really care how i'm doing i
care about a medium amount
[Laughter]
i'm doing fine i'm happy good for you
yeah i'm doing great it's you i think
about now in these moments just because
you're here and i'm interviewing you oh
yeah well getting back to alden pond
would you like nature are you a guy
because you don't seem like a guy who
you don't seem like uh a guy that
frolicks through nature well you don't
like frolic through the woods do you
have a frolic i i frolic a couple days a
year
just for no reason but i go in the woods
and butterflies i don't hunt or anything
but butterflies are the only things that
i'll just kill
[Music]
why would you kill butterflies cause
they're arrogant
they've gotten so many compliments over
the years they just have an attitude you
know
oh look at him oh oh oh
little kids walking by kid's gone i
smash this thing with a rock
you kill butterflies with a rock because
you think they're too full of themselves
yes i'm insane
[Laughter]
and any other animals or that's it just
butterflies butterflies okay
what if you see like a cocoon
would you crush a cocoon
no because get gets into uh free choice
pro-choice that's a pro-choice
[Applause]
how did that help anything
you know i find hardest to believe about
you stephen and i'm going to call you
steven because that's your name uh
that you were a radio dj
at one point
you are so quiet and so monosyllabic i
can't imagine you being a radio what
kind of radio dj were you well i it was
a call i went to emerson college and
they had a couple radio stations and i
wanted to get have a show so they had
auditions for the bluegrass uh
show and i didn't know anything about
bluegrass so i auditioned
so i made up all you know you say the
tape you say and it's a minute i made up
all the bands and i made up all the
songs that the bands were playing and
then i got the show because i think they
were listening to it and they said we
never even heard of this stuff this guy
must be an expert on that
and you just made it up i made it all up
and then i would did the show for a
couple of months but i didn't really
talk much in between i would just play
songs and then i would just say
all right here's another one
here's another one that's fantastic yeah
would you ever take it up again or you
think your those days are over no those
days are over whether they're going to
happen or not i don't know but they're
over
you're causing me to think like this
when i'm not talking to you i'm complete
i'm like an accountant
you're saying you're perfectly sane it's
me it's the presence of me yes all right
that's why we need to talk more often i
believe